foreign
to a suspected con job or eight news now
investigators broke online this
afternoon a man accused of posing as the
owner of the Circa Hotel scheming the
property out of more than a million
dollars eight news now investigator
David charns broke this story he tells
us who the suspect is and how detectives
believe he did it
court documents the 8 news now
investigators obtained reveal police
believe 23-year-old Eric Gutierrez duped
this employee into handing over more
than a million dollars all while
pretending to be the hotel's owner
documents revealing hotel security
called police on June 17 saying someone
contacted the Casino cage asking for
money for an emergency payment to the
fire department documents say the person
who police now know was not the hotel's
owner told a person the fire department
needed to do a check on the fire
extinguishers and they would need a
payment for further safety devices
police say an employee then met off site
with Gutierrez and possibly another
person handing over large amounts of
cash in all nearly 1.2 million dollars
detectives then tracking the vehicle
involved in the suspected theft seen
here in court documents to the
registered owner who according to police
is gutierrez's Aunt police say they
found money at the home the pair shares
all of it in bundles with Circa written
on them
so far police have recovered 850 of that
suspected 1.2 million dollars they say
was stolen right now they don't know
where that other money went or if
someone else may be involved near this
trip I'm David Charles 8 news now David
thank you circus CEO Derek Stevens
telling us quote although I love a good
PR story this isn't one of them Circa is
cooperating with the Las Vegas
Metropolitan Police Department in this
investigation we greatly appreciate
their efforts to date and cannot comment
further due to an ongoing investigation
our a news now investigators also
learning Gutierrez facing a similar
crime in Mesquite we are working to get
more information as to why